[Music]
the game of thrones prequels are coming
and it brings us many legendary
characters
we have house of the dragon and tales of
duncan egg coming our way
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood
volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood volume 1. the aton
released fire and blood volume 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhinera targaryen's son aegon
iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
hbo is also developing a new game of
thrones prequel show based on george r
martin's tales of duncan egg
which followed the adventures of sir
duncan the tall dunk
and young aegon the fifth targaryen egg
90 years prior to the events of a song
of ice and fire
in this video we talk about a character
that is important in both
the targaryen history and the tales of
duncan egg being the main character
himself
aegon egg targaryen aegon the fifth
targaryen was the lord of the seven
kingdoms
and the fifteen targaryen to sit there
and thrown as king of the andals
the rhoynar and the first men in his
youth he went by the nickname egg
and squired for sir duncan at all aegon
became a king after a great council
bypassed a number of candidates earlier
in the line of succession
and after his elder brother maester
aemon refused the throne
as the fourth son of makor the first
himself a fourth son
aegon was called aegon the unlikely
aegon had large eyes which could appear
dark blue
but were actually deep and dark and
purple the boy was pasty faced and
skinny
he shaved his hair to hide his identity
while a squire
making his eyes appear huge on his bald
head aegon wore a wide brimmed floppy
straw hat
while squirring for sir duncan at all
according to a semi-canonical source
the adult aegon had long shoulder-length
hair
that shone like beaten gold with strands
of silver woven together
tall slender and handsome he wore the
crown of aegon iii
aegon grew to become a kindly and
approachable man beloved by small folk
maester raymond who gave the nickname
egg to his brother
believed that aegon had innocence and
sweetness
mother's looking for you
hey aegon was born the fourth son
and fifth child of prince maker
targaryen and his wife
diana dayne aegon served at court in
king's landing
for two years as a page sometimes
attending to the small council
aegon owned a dragon egg which was
colored with green and white swirls and
had been placed in his cradle with him
when he was a babe aegon and his elder
brother prince aemon who we all know as
maestraemon
hoped their eggs would hatch so they
could become dragon riders
aegon kept his zag at summerhall aegon
loathed his brother
the cruel and aryan aegon was supposed
to squire for his zelda's brother daeron
in the tourney at ashford meadow
but thereon had no interest in jousting
and instead
drank himself into a stupor at an end
deron shaved aegon's head
to prevent the boy's distinctive
targaryen hair from being recognized
by men sent by their father prince macor
when the hedge knight dunk visited the
inn he assumed the aegon was a stable
boy
calling himself egg the disguised aegon
had assumed that dunk was short for
duncan
which dunk accepted aegon was impressed
by the humble hedge knight and followed
him
sir duncan the toll agreed to let eggs
serve as his squire during the tourney
duncan was arrested and sentenced to
fight a trial by battle
after attacking ex-elder brother prince
aryan targaryen
duncan was accused by both aryan and his
older brother prince daeron targaryen
who had falsely accused duncan of having
kidnapped prince aegon targaryen
because the battle was to be a trial of
7 aegon convinced her lionel baratheon
to fight on behalf of duncan
aegon's uncle prince baylor breaks beer
also fought alongside duncan during the
trial
but baylor died of a wound inflicted by
prince makor
baylor's brother and aegon's father who
had fought on behalf of aryan and house
targaryen
after deron was defeated daeneryon
withdrew his accusation during the trial
duncan was declared innocent makor the
prince of summerhall wished aegon to be
trained as a knight
but aegon would only agree if duncan
were the knight who trained him
when maker offered duncan a place at the
garrison of summerhall
dunk declined and agreed to take aegon
on only fagon accompanied him as his
choir
aegon would live humbly but duncan
thought it would make aegon a better man
than his brothers
aryan and darwin thus sagon served as a
squire to the duncan under his nickname
egg
aegon kept his identity secret from the
public while squirring for duncan
and he kept hidden in his boat a signet
ring from his father
make or targaryen prince of summerhall
aegon married lady betha blackwood in
220ac
the marriage at the time provoked no
opposition as aegon was very low in the
line of succession
they married for love and eventually had
five children together
aegon named his first born son duncan to
honor his friend
sir duncan the tall in 221 ac
aegon's uncle king aerys the first
targaryen died with no issue
and was followed on the iron throne by
his last living brother
prince make or targaryen aegon and his
brothers were summoned
to court by king macor according to a
semi-canon source
aegon participated in the suppression of
the peak uprising in 233 ac
with theon lannister as a squire
kingmaker the first was killed at star
pike during the rebellion however
according to a semi can on swords the
prince knighted
the mortally wounded tiveled lannister
theon's twin during the battle
with maekor dead it was unclear who
should be the king
since two of fagon's older brothers had
died before his father
darren left a feeble witted daughter
named vela
and aryan an infant son so great counsel
was called to choose a king
aegon seemed the logical choice but many
lords considered him half a peasant
due to his youth among the small folk
the council approached taegon's older
brother maester aemon
but he refused stating the crown should
be given to aegon
aegon was crowned lord of the seven
kingdoms in 233 ac
when he was 33 years old during the most
if not
all of aeg on the fifth train his old
friend sir duncan the toll served as
lord commander of the kingsguard
aegon's first act as a king was the
arrest of lord brian
rivers the hand of the king for the
murder of aeneas blackfyre
as bloodraven had offered dany's saved
conduct to westeros for the great
council
but had anes executed when he arrived in
the capital
although all were glad another blackfyre
pretender was dead
aegon had to punish lord bloodraven to
prove the word of the armed round was
not worthless
although bryden was sentenced to death
aegon allowed him to join the night's
watch
aegon's brother mr raymond decided to
join the night's watch as well
to prevent any plots in which he would
be used against his brother
bryden and aemon were joined by many of
bloodraven's personal guard
the raven's teeth as well as prisoners
released from dungeons by the king
the end of winter saw the return of the
black fire pretenders
with the fourth blackfyre rebellion
taking place in 236
ac daemon iii blackfyre attempted to
seize the iron throne with the golden
company
but few rallied to his side aegon and
his sons rode
to meet and repel the invaders and
duncan the tolls slew daemon in single
combat
ending the rebellion ago rivers known as
bittersteel managed to flee with
remnants of the golden company across
the narrow sea
aegon v spent much of his reign dealing
with uprisings
most of aegon's troubles resulted from
his efforts to improve the lives of the
small folk
whom he had interacted with while
squirring for duncan
lacking the dragons controlled by early
targaryen kings
aegon reluctantly compromised with
disobedient lords on several issues
aegon faced renewed troubles in his
reign caused by his sons
convinced the targaryen practice of
incestuous marriage was harmful after
spending time with smallfolk
aegon and his queen bathed a blackwood
betrothed four of their children to some
of the great houses of the seven
kingdoms in 237 ac
their eldest son and heir prince duncan
was betrothed to the daughter of lord
lionel baratheon of storm's end
prince jaehaery sagan's second son was
betrothed to lady celia tully
the daughter of the lord of reverend
aegon's youngest son prince daron was
betrothed to lady elena redwine of the
arbor
who would later become known to all of
us as lady elena terrell
i wasn't originally meant to marry your
grandfather luther you know
he was engaged to my sister your
great-aunt
viola i was to be given to some
targaryen or other
marrying a targaryen was all the rage
back then
but the moment i saw my intended with
his
twitchy little fetish face and ludicrous
silver hair
i knew he wouldn't do in addition
aegon's eldest daughter princess sheira
was betrothed to luther tyrell the heir
to highgarden
the proposed marriages would have won
aegon much support for his reforms
but his children had inherited his
willfulness and their mother's
stubbornness
beginning in 239 ac prince duncan fell
in love with and eventually vetted the
mysterious jenny of old stones
the prince chose his wife over the iron
throne and abdicated as prince of
dragonstone
making his younger brother prince
jeharis the new heir
with duncan refusing to marry the
daughter of lord baratheon
storm zen briefly rose in rebellion
which ended with sir duncan the toll of
the kingsguard
forced lord lionel to yield during trial
by combat
the duncan marrying jenny as president
jacary sanchez secretly wed and
consummated their marriage in 240 ac
leaving aegon to deal with the anger of
hausa stali and tyrell
aldo betrothed for nine years to lay the
elena redwine
prince daeron broke his betrothal in 246
ac
in 258 ac 9 outlaws
exiles pirates and cell swords hoping to
carve out individual
kingdoms came together in the disputed
lands of essos
among this band of nine was melees the
first blackfyre
the last of the blackfyres because the
outlaws had no great urgency
king aegon remained intent on his reign
and on dragons in particular
against the advice of his friends and
counselors
aegon v became convinced that only with
dragons could he force the lords of the
seven kingdoms to accept his decrees
that granted freedoms rights and
protections to the small folk
this eventually led to the tragedy of
summerhall in 259 ac
in which aegon perished while trying to
hatch dragon x
his son prince duncan the small his
friend and lord commander of the
kingsguard sir duncan the tall
and others of the royal court also
perished in the fire
aegon was succeeded by his second son
and heir jaehaerys ii
many of the laws rights and protections
king aegon the fifth had granted and
bestowed upon the small folk
were later undone and during the reign
of king heiress ii by the hand of the
king
lord time in lannister many interesting
characters targaryens and others
many legendary figures that are
immortalized in many songs and stories
all of that and more the game of thrones
prequel shows are bringing to us
starting with the house of the dragon in
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace